una Francia que está buscando gasolina
en todo el territorio inmensas filas de
espera para encontrar combustible esta
mañana ni una gota de gasolina en esta
estación de servicio
esta ni siquiera funciona quiere decir
que no hay gasolina
me quedé sin combustible Estoy buscando
gasolina pero no hay nada la gasolinera
fue por fin abastecida apenas llegó el
conductor del camión cisterna que se
encontró rodeado de gente
Hola señor Qué productos lleva
gasoil sin plomo e10 dietanol más de 30
ML de carburante las filas se formaron
apenas conectaron los tubos
[Música]
ya están esperando atrás hay fila
estamos felices de verlo porque estamos
buscando gasoil desde hace tres días
ahora ustedes como Papá Noel antes de
Navidad
más moderado para otros clientes tenemos
para una semana y veremos para la
próxima semana preocupado para los
próximos días Este motorista de Marsella
hizo reservas
fui a 10 estaciones y las 10 no tenían
gasolina entonces hay que dejar de decir
que creamos la escasez porque realmente
existe la escasez este profesional de la
construcción pasa a todos Ya en la bomba
yo la dejo el trabajo llevo un camión
lleno el tanque y voy para el otro
camión
otros no quisieran arriesgar de quedarse
sin gasolina en la región estos buses
escolares no funcionaron los padres
tuvieron que venir recoger a sus niños a
la escuela vivimos en el mismo pueblo
entonces ayer Nos contactamos Para
organizarnos para saber quién les
llevaría por la mañana y quién le
recogería por la tarde obviamente es
incómodo para todo el mundo pero
entendemos los salarios son un verdadero
problema de fondo
tus anunciaron que seguirán la huelga
Este martes 15 gasolineras adicionales
se unirán al